before my helpless sight he plunges at
me guttering choking drowning poet
Wilfred Owen recounts the horror of gas
in the trenches of World War one as the
Second World War began
Yale scientists were engaged in defense
research searching for antidotes to
these chemical weapons so dreaded that
they were referred to only by code names
pharmacists Lewis s Goodman and Alfred
Gilman discovered that mustard gas could
be a potent weapon against another enemy
cancer Yale played an incredibly
important role in cancer therapy
chemotherapy was discovered at Yale
doctors Goodman and Gilman were doing
research on nitrogen mustard this was
during World War two they found the
nitrogen mustard was able to
experimentally shrink cancers in mice
Goodman and Gilman then went on to
demonstrate with dr. Lin Skog that you
could give nitrogen mustard to patients
and they gave it to a man here at Yale
with lymphoma and found that at rank his
cancer this was really the first
demonstration of this and it led to
dramatic improvements in how we treat
diseases like lymphoma leukemia
childhood cancers the ability to profile
the genes that cause cancer is extremely
important every patients cancer started
with a genetic abnormality either a
mutation in their genes or an increased
number of copies of a gene or an
inactivation of a gene that led to the
development of cancer this allows
investigators to take a patient's cancer
profile that cancer find out which genes
are abnormal and then direct specific
therapies against that genetic change
building on the foundation laid by
Goodman Gilman Lyn Skog and their
successors Yale scientists are
developing personalized medicine
therapies that are customed to be
precisely effective for an individual
patient with fewer side effects and so
another revolution in cancer treatment
is
away